HOST: All right,
guys, congratulations.
You both made it to round three
of the competition, where we
will send you to your
home forges for four days
to make this iconic weapon
from US military history.
And that weapon is--
the Springfield 1905 bayonet.
We will be providing
a Springfield
1903 replica rifle to you.
Your bayonets must fit snugly
and securely on your rifle.
[bleep].
NARRATOR: Developed
in the early 1900s,
the M1905 Springfield
bayonet was
used by American infantry
for nearly 70 years,
from World War I
through the Vietnam War.
These versatile
weapons were designed
with a mechanical device and the
pommel that attached securely
to the rifle, while also
featuring a comfortable handle,
making it a very effective
weapon in hand-to-hand combat.
Featuring a sharp single edge,
a long fuller, and a false edge,
this lightweight bayonet
could quickly deliver stabs
and slashes to an opponent.
The bayonet is still used today
during military ceremonies
and can be seen in
several classic war films,
like 1998's "The Thin Red Line."
HOST: All right, gentlemen, when
you guys build your bayonets,
I want you to follow
these parameters.
Your blade needs to be between
15 and 16 inches, with a fuller
and a false edge at the tip,
as well as a muzzle ring guard.
JOSH: I'm a little
nervous with it.
I've never done a guard
on a knife before,
let alone with a keyhole.
And I know with the
bayonets, they usually
have a place in the
back of the handle
where it locks into the rifle.
There's a lot of firsts.
All right,
gentlemen, good luck.
We'll see you in four days.
Good luck, man.
Yeah.
BRAD: My main plan is to get
the whole blade forged out.
I guess I could
grind it to shape.
But then it's not
forged in fire.
BRAD: I have
everything forged out.
Fullers are in.
Rough dimensions are there.
I'm happy.
So right now, I
have my groove cut.
These are gonna be
the rest of my pommel.
They are going to go like so,
and then be welded like that.
So I have to use my angle
grinder very, very, very
carefully and scribe
this line in thick enough
that it fits on those rails.
Line everything up.
Hey!
It works.
BRAD: I got my
scales all cut out.
They fit relatively nice.
Now I'm working
on getting my pin.
But that's gonna look
pretty cool when it's done.
I have my knife all glued up.
Now that it's dry, I'm ready
to take the clamps off.
And we'll start
profiling the handle.
At the end process,
it's probably one
of the best things I've made.
I'm pretty proud of this.
JOSH (VOICEOVER): So I'm back
in Lancaster, Ohio, at my home
forge.
I've never made anything
this big before.
All right, so got the
edges cleaned up fairly well.
Overall, my knife
is pretty straight.
It's got some little wobbles in
there, but that's from forging.
A little less than an 1/8 of an
inch to remove from this thing,
and we're good.
JOSH: I'm going to
clench my knife.
There's a lot of things that
can go wrong in this process.
Let's do this.
So I'm not hearing any
weird noises or any pings.
So I think I'm in good shape.
The biggest challenge
of this build is getting
that locking mechanism to work.
So now, we're going
to test fit this.
There she is.
I try to really pride
myself on my fit and finish,
and I'm pretty
confident in my knife.
I'm really happy with it.
I wouldn't want to be on
the other end of this thing.
Let's see what it does.
Yeah, this thing is sweet.
Let's see.
[laughs]
This thing is sharp.
Dude, that didn't
even make any noise.
It just stabbed
right through it.
Bladesmiths, welcome
to the Kill Test.
The first mission today
is to take your bayonet
and affix it to the
Springfield rifle
and deliver some killing blows
on this ballistics dummy.
Then I will dismantle
the blade from the rifle,
and let's see what
kind of lethal damage
it will do on its own.
Josh, you're up first.
You ready?
As ready as I can be.
That's pretty bad ass.
DOUG: All right, Josh, let's
talk about your bayonet here.
When I affixed this
onto the rifle,
it had a very nice
match with the railing
in there and your pin.
It was very secure.
Now, your edge is very sharp.
It definitely lacerates
deep into the bone.
On its own, the
handle construction
matches nicely on my hand.
Overall, sir, it will kill.
Awesome.
Thank you.
All right, Brad, your turn.
So are you ready for this?
Let's go for it.
Ooh.
DOUG: All right, Brad, first
up, the handle construction.
It is a little bit
on the smaller side.
But there are no sharp edges.
And the flair you
have here actually
gives me good
retention, and I can
get all the way to the guard.
At first, I was a little bit
worried about your cotter
pin right here.
It looked flimsy.
But the minute I put it on,
it wasn't an issue at all.
It stayed affixed to the
bayonet quite tightly.
Your weapon is straight.
Every cut was very deep
into this ballistics dummy.
Overall, sir, your
weapon will kill.
Thank you, sir.
BEN ABBOTT: Bladesmiths,
welcome to the Strength Test,
the Steel Can Stab
and Barricade Chop.
This test is all about what
happens to your bayonets
and not what happens
to the targets.
Josh, you're up first.
Are you ready?
Nope.
No.
[bleep]
Well, here's my finish.
All right, Josh.
Well, it survived really well.
There is sections
on here that are
now not as sharp as they were.
But nothing rolled over,
nothing chipped out.
Your point is still
nice and sharp.
It performed really well
on the Strength Test.
Nice job.
- Awesome.
Thank you.
All right, Brad, are
you ready for this?
Well, my nan said don't
break it, but go for it.
BEN ABBOTT: Well, Brad,
what you got here,
your blade edge
took some damage.
The blade has taken a bit
of a bend to one side here.
It's cheating to the right.
But your point didn't
take any damage.
It's all in one piece.
It's a nice sturdy blade.
Nice job.
Thank you.
All right, bladesmiths,
this is the Sharpness
Test, the Military Bag Slice.
To find out how sharp your edges
and point of your bayonets are,
I'm gonna take a stab
at these military bags.
Josh, you're up first.
You ready?
Let's go for it.
All right, Josh,
your bayonet right
here had no problems
puncturing the bag
and slicing it to pieces.
It'll cut.
Sweet.
Thanks.
All right, Brad,
your turn, sir.
Shall we do it?
Of course.
Have at you.
Pew, pew, pew.
[laughter]
All right, Brad, let's
talk about your blade here.
Wicked sharp.
It punctured easily
in the military bag.
At the same time, the edges
cut like hot steel on butter.
Overall, sir, for this
test, it will cut.
Thank you, sir.
HOST: All right,
gentleman, while you
both brought us amazing
work, only one of you
will go home with the title.
And the "Forged in
Fire" Champion is--
Josh.
Holy [bleep].
HOST: Congratulations.
Brad, unfortunately, you're not
going home with the win today.
And Doug's gonna tell you why.
I commend you on your work.
Your knife performed
very well on our test.
But it was also the
only knife that took
a bend on the strength test.
And for that reason, your
blade did not make the cut.
HOST: Brad,
unfortunately, that means
I'm gonna have to ask you to
please leave the Forge Floor.
I understand.
Have a good one, guys.
Pleasure, man.
Thank you.
BRAD: When it comes to the
judges' final decision,
I can't argue with it at all.
I am extremely proud of my work.
That was probably the best
blade I've ever made so far.
This has just been
a dream come true.
And I'm just so grateful
to be where I am right
now, even if I am going home.
Well, Josh, that means you are
the "Forged in Fire" Champion.
You're going home with
a check for $10,000.
How does it feel, bud?
I feel awesome.
Congratulations.
JOSH: I don't even know, man.
I'm still trying
to sink in that I--
I won this--
I won.
It's a little overwhelming.
I can't wait to tell my wife.
She had a lot of confidence
in me from the very start.
I'm excited to let
her know that, hey,
you-- you were right, you know?
I won.
[music playing]